ah
como está bien bien sé que en todos
estos años que he trabajado como rector
me ha pasado algo muy muy característico
y es que me siento con los diferentes
rectores de las universidades públicas y
privadas y siempre nos quejamos de lo
mismo es que los chavos llegan mal
preparados a la universidad no saben
leer no saben escribir tienen mil
errores de ortografía no tienen
habilidades sociales no son
emprendedores una cantidad de cosas
entonces dije el problema tiene que
estar en la educación media superior en
las preparatorias y entonces me fui con
los directores de preparatoria y le dije
oye qué pasa están formando mal a los
jóvenes y me dicen hombre el problema no
somos nosotros es las secundarias ahí
algo está funcionando mal y entonces me
fui a las secundarias y me dijeron no
aquí no es el problema es en primaria y
me fui a primar y me dijeron no el
problema es en el kinder y en los kinder
que les tocó decir que los papás no se
comprometen al final
nadie tiene la razón de por qué estamos
funcionando mal y entonces me di a la
tarea de viajar por diferentes partes
del mundo a conocer lo que hacen bien y
mal los sistemas educativos y encontré
algo bien interesante que la mayoría de
los sistemas educativos en américa
latina están centrados en la
memorización y entonces a un niño lo
atacan y le dicen dime la fecha de
nacimiento de esta persona dime cuánto
mide el río más largo dime cuál es la
altura de tal volcán y entonces nos
olvidamos de hacerlos entender que lo
verdaderamente importante del
conocimiento es construir nuevo
conocimiento de qué sirve que un niño se
sepa cuáles son todas las capitales del
mundo si no sabe que es una forma de
gobierno y cómo va a afectar a un país
de qué les sirve saber cuál es la
montaña más alta si no entiende que hoy
en el planeta 1.100 millones de personas
no comieron absolutamente nada
y entonces hace unos años me peleé con
una maestra la maestra de estas duras
que me decía que todo el que la letra
con sangre entra y yo le decía mire
maestra a mí me importan tres cacahuetes
la fecha de nacimiento de benito juárez
se molestó mucho y me dijo sacrilegio
como se le ocurre decir eso rector el
benemérito de las américas
yo le dije miren la fecha de nacimiento
de benito juárez o de cualquier prócer
es una casualidad no importa que sea el
21 de marzo en oaxaca
lo importante es cuáles fueron los 5
valores más importantes del gobierno de
benito juárez y cómo se podrían aplicar
hoy en méxico en el 2010 y nuevo en
cualquier país de américa latina porque
el respeto al derecho ajeno es la paz
cuando hoy tenemos más de 300.000
muertos sólo en mexico y sumen los de
américa latina' entonces ahí se todo
más importante el pensamiento crítico de
un niño
y entonces a uno le dicen oye
te sabes la tabla del 7 por supuesto me
la enseñaron de memoria 7 por unos 7 7
por 2 14 te sabes la tabla del 250 hay
nuevo es súper difícil pero que no 250
por 2 500 250 por 3 750 es muy fácil
cuando empiezas a analizar que
simplemente sumando logras un objetivo
entonces qué quiero decir con esto que
el sistema educativo se está equivocando
cuando se entra en simplemente pensar
que los cerebros de los niños son
recipientes donde tenemos que meter una
gran cantidad de información que
simplemente está ahí para que aprobar un
examen necesitamos que ese conocimiento
se convierta en que el nuevo
conocimiento entonces
esta es la hipótesis del siglo 21 el
conocimiento es el nuevo petróleo del
mundo petróleo se va a acabar se va a
acabar no solo porque se va acabar
físicamente porque es un recurso no
renovable se va a acabar porque el mundo
ya no quiere usar petróleo y entonces
los países han entendido que el
conocimiento es lo que va a sostener las
economías esto lo han desarrollado la
mayoría de los países importantes y que
hacen para eso tienen un buen sistema
educativo hay un solo país que tenga un
mal sistema educativo que tenga riqueza
estamos condenados a la pobreza si no
tenemos un buen sistema educativo y
entonces fíjense estos son datos de la
ompi de la organización mundial de la
propiedad intelectual del 2017 eeuu
registró más de 150 mil patentes ahí ven
ustedes chinas que en los setentas
tenían muchísimos problemas pasó de
300.000 patentes registradas nuevos
conocimientos
corea del sur que hace 30 años tenía una
economía menor que la de nosotros hoy
tiene casi 91 mil patentes registradas y
como esta américa latina mexico 407
patentes colombia 166 y brasil- 714 en
una economía del conocimiento nos
estamos dando un tiro en la cabeza
y esto hablando de innovación también un
estudio que se hizo en 70 países donde
se analizó quiénes son los países más
innovadores
miren el primero y miren de los 70
países en qué lugares estamos los de
américa latina- la realidad es que
nuestro sistema educativo no está
funcionando como lo necesitamos y
mientras no funcione vamos a estar
condenados a la pobreza que hay que
hacer no vamos a hacer vamos a buscar
una solución porque claro hay gente que
dice oiga es que si se tiene que
memorizar para aprender claro que hay
que memorizar por supuesto pero no
simplemente memorizar para dejarlo ahí
es memorizar para construir nuevo
conocimiento esta es la primera cosa que
hay que hacer esta es una definición de
educación que a mí me costó 20 años y
que todavía está en construcción
hay que formar jóvenes creativos la
creatividad no es un tema de pintores o
artistas es una manera de vivir que
generen
innovación aplicada a problemas
cotidianos o al nuevo conocimiento pero
saben que generando riqueza desarrollo
para un país yo le digo mucho a mis
alumnos cada que me siento con ellos les
digan miren cuando ustedes salen a la
calle y se encuentra en un bache tienen
dos caminos el primero es criticar a las
autoridades hoy es que se roban el
dinero porque no tapan los baches pero
la segunda es
no me uno con un chavo de la universidad
tecnológica y con uno de la universidad
autonóma y vamos a crear un pavimento en
base a material reciclado que se llaman
a menor costo y más fácil aplicarlo
siempre los problemas son una solución
para algo pero tenemos que llevar al
sistema educativo para que la innovación
sea el objetivo no importa maestra si te
sientes muy conductista o
constructivista o si las cualquier tipo
de modelo que quieras usar o si las
competencias es lo que tú buscas genera
innovación y la innovación tiene que
salir de la emoción un niño que no está
emocionado frente al aprendizaje primero
no va feliz a la escuela y segundo no va
a poder generar ningún conocimiento la
segunda cosa es bien interesante miren
este concepto lo he denominado los 4
analfabetismos
la primera revolución industrial a
finales del siglo 18 fue la que la marcó
las máquinas a vapor y entonces el tren
a vapor y los barcos y todo esto y fue
muy importante que la gente supiera leer
y escribir no entonces era importante
que tú empezarás a salir de esa
ignorancia en que estaban pero después
viene una segunda revolución industrial
y en la revolución lo que se hacía en
serie no coches en ser y viene todas las
fábricas y habían dos países que
empezaron a liderar todo esto que eran
eeuu e inglaterra y también eran varios
países de europa entonces al liderar
eeuu e inglaterra
el inglés se volvió la necesidad mundial
se volvió el idioma de los negocios
entonces quien no sabía inglés pues
había un problema porque era el idioma
de los negocios incluso en la actualidad
pero después viene la tercera revolución
industrial la de las computadoras no la
del internet casi finales del siglo 20 y
entonces quien no sabía manejar una
computadora
bien era una o es una analfabeta pero
ojo estamos en la cuarta revolución
industrial la revolución de la
inteligencia artificial las redes
neuronales entonces hoy se vuelve
prioritario que nuestros niños en el
sistema educativo entiendan conceptos de
inteligencia artificial sepan conocer
lenguajes de programación entiendan que
es una red neuronal pero si ustedes
analizan esos cuatro analfabetismos en
méxico apenas estamos en la primera
parte estamos resolviendo el que la
gente por fin pueda leer y escribir el
100 por ciento de la gente inglés menos
del 5 por ciento de los mexicanos
hablamos inglés computadoras vámonos al
sur de méxico y seguramente no saben
mucha gente usar una computadora y ni se
diga inteligencia artificial tenemos un
grave problema mientras el mundo va muy
rápido nosotros estamos estáticos porque
nuestro sistema educativo no está
generando las soluciones que se
necesitan pero ahí va la tercera
tenemos 10 cosas que enseñar además de
todo el currículum que puede venir en un
plan de estudios la gente necesita tomar
decisiones saber tomar decisiones pero
saben que resolviendo problemas eso es
fundamental nos cuesta mucho a los
latinoamericanos tomar decisiones no lo
critican mucho la segunda
tenemos que desarrollar inteligencia
emocional saben que cuando yo estudié a
mí me decían los niños no lloran los
hombres no lloran porque claro que
lloramos y nos gusta llorar y es
importante llorar
es importante entender las emociones y
los sentimientos de los demás tercero la
creatividad como modo de vida cuarto que
se adapten fácilmente hoy una persona
vive en aguascalientes mañana en londres
y regresa a bolivia y después se va a
argentina
así es tienen que entender su
mexicanidad su cultura pero saberse
adaptar al mundo donde les toque vivir
quinto asumir riesgos que no les dé
miedo enfrentarse a las cosas 6 trabajar
en equipo es imposible hoy construir
algo
no es de manera interrelacionada 6 ser
resilientes saben que nos dicen los
emprendedores hoy fracasa rápido
límpiate las rodillas las lágrimas y al
otro día en frente al mundo la
resiliencia hoy es fundamental para
cualquier niño en el sistema educativo
pero también tener un pensamiento
crítico no solo me aprendo la fecha de
nacimiento de benito juárez sé qué fue
lo importante que pasó con él o de
cualquier prócer o de cualquier historia
importante del mundo no 9 ser sensibles
algún día escribió una frase que me
encanta mucho que dice una sociedad que
pierde la capacidad de sentir el dolor
del otro está perdida si a mí estudiante
oa mi hijo le importa un bledo los
inmigrantes centroamericanos de los
semáforos señores estamos perdidos
vivimos una sociedad que estamos como en
una cápsula donde no nos importa lo que
pasa alrededor y la realidad es que
tenemos que poner los pies en la tierra
enseñarles a nuestros niños la realidad
para que la puedan mejorar y saben que
la 10a
tenemos que ser perseverantes tenemos
que trabajar una otra vez y lo ensayo y
me cuesta y la cuarta cosa que tenemos
que hacer es ser emprendedores pero no
solo emprendedores tradicionales
esta es una tesis que desarrollen una
maestría y es en américa latina' el
sistema educativo está centrado a formar
empleados es una realidad muchos de
nosotros nos educaron para que al
terminar nuestra carrera hiciéramos
-unos currículums y buscáramos amigos en
el gobierno o en alguna empresa para que
nos dieran chamba no así nos educaron
pero ojo hay otros países que están
formando emprendedores pero hay un grupo
de países que están formando
emprendedores de pensamiento exponencial
qué quiere decir eso la gente que ha
entendido que con el uso de la
tecnología de la inteligencia artificial
de las redes neuronales pueden llegar a
7500 millones de personas cuál es mi
reto en lo que hago cada día en
educación
salto cuántico de formar empleados a
formar pensadores emprendedores de
pensamiento exponencial para qué
para que cree en este tipo de empresas
estas empresas que tienen un alto
crecimiento empresas que han entendido
que con la tecnología fácilmente pueden
llegar a 7500 millones de personas
entonces cuatro cosas formar niños en
innovación segundo enseñarles que
entiendan redes neuronales pensamiento
exponencial tercero las diez llaves y
cuarto formar emprendedores
exponenciales para qué
este mundo en el que vivimos es un mundo
hermoso tiene cosas maravillosas pero
lastimosamente nuestras generaciones han
hecho mucho daño hoy tenemos unas
desigualdades terribles entre ricos y
pobres unas desigualdades que nos van a
llevar al colapso pues hoy tenemos que
formar niños y jóvenes diferentes para
que puedan construir el mundo donde
todos queremos vivir muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]